oh my god
like like at gunpoint or something
you you're so sweet that's so freaking
like it's the second time
oh my god what the hell okay no thank
you
i'd probably ship my pants but no i mean
like i've definitely been robbed at
gunpoint i mean like not me
like might not have that held at my head
but like when i was in the car with
somebody
like that's wild
it's loud out there today some days are
quiet down here and other days they're
just loud today
oh my gosh i'm kind of nervous like yeah
everybody gets nervous you'll be fine
i'm gonna ask you questions you already
know okay
because i wasn't just like i was like
there's
what's that that's just to sink the tube
the audio when i
something like so interesting to me like
i love this i mean
it seems like such a fun job too fun and
dangerous and dangerous
i mean yeah dangerous is fun so
yeah i guess it's like skid row it's fun
and dangerous yeah i mean why not
soon right nicole yes nicole
where are you from where'd you grow up i
grew up in the bay area uh california
and uh it's up north um so i grew up in
a
i actually grew up in oakland california
and then in the hills
um oakland hills and then moved to san
leandro and then to alameda
so i did a lot of moving around a lot of
moving around just at a young age
how was your family as a kid um my
family is a kid well i'm an only child
so my mom and my dad um you know they
had me they worked a ton
and i never really saw them at all so my
grandparents
really took me in um took me to school
um you know picked me up from school
took me all my doctor's appointments and
stuff like that
um they pretty much raised me and my my
parents saw me at night one like once in
a while
but while i was growing up like they my
mom's an alcoholic
and my dad's kind of one of those aloof
kind of like doesn't really like
you know even like kind of denies it and
like there was a lot of violence
in my household um they would constantly
fight like aggressively fight throw
things at each other and like i'd be
hitting each other you know bad fighting
and as a kid and only child i felt
i had nobody you know and i just would
hate hang out in the closet and
a lot of the times like i would just
that was my spot
and i would just like sit there and just
cry like it was sad but like
that's kind of like all i knew growing
up
um it was tough um yeah it was like
really lonely like i remember i had a
lot of animosity towards my mom my dad
for not having more kids
i always thought like why like i'd
always be like why couldn't you have
more kids like i hate this like
my mom's an only child as well so you
know i'd always be like
you know how it felt wrong because it
really was lonely i hate
i always tell people that i know like
that are pregnant i'm like
have another kid like you know like
don't it's lonely but
you know and then i was my grandparents
you know so they're like uh
obviously older so you know it was kind
of boring like you know
and just like i didn't have anybody i
felt very alone and so i think that's
why like
like down here is a big reason and like
i like
a lot like i know it's dangerous
whatever but
on the other hand it's like you've meet
some of the most loving people i've ever
met down here
so i don't know and i think that
loneliness brought on a lot of like
um stuff that i'm going through now in
my life like i'm an addict
um you know i'm a i'm a drug addict
um so um
well really started with alcohol and
like that started in like high school
i you know did the typical like party
girl like i was like the party girl
friends and yeah there's a group of
seven of us that like
i'm still friends with to this day but
uh we like partied a lot you know we did
like uh coke was probably the next thing
and that was probably like
around like 20s like after high school
and then um
i started just that's when i was like
i'm thinking i'm going
now i'm all like um but yeah so then it
moved on to like you know harder stuff
it did it was the typical like gateway
drug and then
the alcohol and then it more and more
piled on
coke and then i started doing
methamphetamine like
i'd say like a couple years ago and then
um about two years ago as well i started
doing
um heroin and um now the
now the end thing like fentanyl
everyone's starting to do fentanyl and
that's that's what's doing heroin
because it's stronger you know
um all that stuff so i'm currently on
fentanyl
yeah apparently yeah so that is a
huh be careful with that yeah it's sad
it's like me and my friends were talking
about it and um
we were saying that it's it's sick but
um
it's the truth because like like someone
will say someone will overdose
and you know as an addict you just want
the best powerful like [ __ ] out there
you want the most like heart you want
the best high you want to get that high
that's all we're
you know searching for and so like when
you hear about someone overdosing like
you're like oh my gosh like i want
like where'd they pick up where'd they
get that bag cause i want that bag
you know what i mean like it's so sick
cause you're like it's just
it's a sick thing so yeah we're
currently on fentanyl i'm really
trying to get lean i don't want to live
like this i mean i've been
you know crying i spent a lot of time
days crying like just
praying to god like to like let this
disease
you know free me because i've been
captive to it i feel like a prisoner
like in my own body
um for years now like the last two years
have just been
how absolute hell and you know i just so
badly want to be free from it you know
but
it's hard it's really what do you think
people don't understand about trying to
quit drugs
because because so many people like i'll
read the comments sometimes and people
say oh just quit get back to your family
yeah what i think people don't
understand is that
it's not us anymore what like it's not
me
like anymore like once the drug like
it's like i'm dependent on it and once i
feel i need it like
nicole's not there anymore you know the
drug takes over and i feel like a lot of
people take it
so personally like like i'm the first
like i'm doing these things like i don't
know like
it's not me like i am not the drug like
and the drug is not me and like
like we become almost one what i'm using
and like
a lot of people forget like that it's
like i'm not this person
just because i'm doing bad things and i
i i maybe come off it was like
disgusting drug addict like as my mother
likes to say even though she's a [ __ ]
alcoholic
um i you know i'm not you know that's
not me anymore and
i'm sick if there was a choice the
choice might have been
years ago when you first picked up
the cocaine or whatever right yeah but
the choice
is no longer a choice now yeah it's a
necessity yeah it'd be
yeah at first i believe like it's more
important than breathing right yeah oh
yeah
yeah totally and um i believe that it's
a disease of choice like is what i
always say like at first you like yeah
you have to like if you're clean after
like you're good you're clean you got
clean
you know it's a choice to pick that up
again but after you have gotten clean
and you know you're working the sobriety
game and you're getting sober and you're
in recovery um yeah and you pick up
again that
is a choice but once you're you picked
up again there
you're that's it like you know that
there is no choice like it's
it it literally controls your whole life
like it is more important than breathing
like and it's like
crazy like i don't i don't think like
right now i don't think i
i can't remember the last time i had
like a good meal except for last night
when
you know uber gave me that meal like
that was the last time i like eaten in
like
probably a couple weeks what kind of
things that maybe people that don't use
drugs to take for granted in their lives
do you not experience like like eating
well like
literally like sleeping sleeping like
water like like having like
i don't know it's like okay let's see
yeah like that's what i meant like
taking a shower
like taking a freaking like a
[ __ ] in a nice bathroom or like like i
don't know just
you know being like in somewhere they
can be whether
if it's raining like they have a roof
over their head like it's just like the
littlest things like
i don't know like i took a shower the
other day and i was just like in the
shower and i was like crying because i
was like this is so
amazing like and then i thought to
myself i'm like these are things that
like
years ago like i would have never
questioned like how much comfort is
there in your in your life
comfort yeah right now
there isn't any like besides the
drawings that's what i was just
yeah like that's why like when i use
drugs like i'm like
that's like comfort that's a lot of
people go through their lives and
they sleep in a comfortable bed they sit
on a comfortable sofa they sit in a warm
comfortable house yeah they wake up to a
nice comfortable breakfast
and everything's yeah around comfort
your your existence is about
survival and if you would have known me
like in high school like uh
even like beginning like i went to
community college like even the
beginning years of like community
college like
you would have never guessed like i went
home for her i actually went home for
christmas
this year and i saw some of my my best
girlfriends that i went to school with
and they were like
we would have never known we would have
never known like
that you would turn out like this and
like that hurts like that hurts to hear
you know
you don't look like a drug addict and
they you know you could go to santa
monica right now and
really walk around and no one would say
oh my god look at that drug addict
really
because like in my body and in my head
like
i feel like i look like the most
disgusting thing out there like i feel
like i look
disgusting and i think that's like the
drug kind of telling me like
you look disgusting you are disgusting
like like that's like
like the type of things i tell myself
when i'm on drugs because
i feel like i'm a loser i feel just like
and i
look at when i look at myself like
that's what i see like a disgusting drug
but it's funny you've been i'm sorry go
ahead no i was gonna say like other
people will say like you look good or
like you don't look like a drug addict
and like i'm like
are you kidding me no you definitely
don't but how long have you been
homeless
um i've been homeless god
it's the last year full i'd say the full
for
like fully because i would stay i would
go and like my parents would take me
back and let me stay with them
but like fully homeless like the last
like year but
living this kind of life where you're
doing drugs and homelessness well
internet like i've been to treatment
it's not like i haven't got tried to get
clean before i have been treatment like
seven
five seven times yeah so so i guess my
point is
when you're living this stuff this kind
of life
the respect and dignity that a person
might have in a normal
existence is gone yeah so all of a
sudden you're like beaten down
your self-worth is beaten down to you
know you see yourself as beautiful and
and attractive or anything like that
whereas you you as an
outsider who just met you you look
beautiful and you're
attractive as can be but you're not and
you certainly don't look like a drug
addict but you don't see it that way
no i don't see it that way at all that's
why it's is shame a big part of that
yeah shame um a big one for me is guilt
um i miss a lot of things like because
of drugs and alcohol i mean i missed
like
my grandparents that the ones that
raised me i was really close but they
my grandma just died like like in
october no
you're hauled again 29 29. yeah she just
died this last past year and i wasn't
there to
to see her go i wasn't you know i was
too
busy doing drugs and getting uh and like
partying as my mom likes to say but it's
like not a party anymore
and you know you know it's like that's
another thing that i think a lot of
people who don't use drugs
um kind of like don't realize
is that they think like it's a party or
something like oh i'm having all this
fun but it's not fun anymore
you know it's not fun anymore it becomes
a time where it's just like
absolutely hell and what what emotions
do you deal with less
what emotions do i deal with mostly did
you get depressed oh yeah i
i grew up when i grew up grew up i was
depressed i you know a lot of anxiety
um but yeah depression is a big one i
really hard on myself so
i am get down on myself a lot and i get
really sad
and i get really um emotionally like
distraught like i just
i can't find comfort in anything besides
like numbing it it seems
like you have no kids no kids how do you
escape having kids because so many women
around your age in this lifestyle like
they've had seven kids and
they're not raising any of them how i
escaped i birth control
not even not even i i i did have a
couple abortions
but i just
i just i don't know i don't want to say
i got lucky because like
i want them to come off as rude like
like people have kids like oh like
that you know that stuff like i just i
don't know i
i just kind of knew what i did knew that
i didn't want kids
until i was like 100 ready and 100
able to give the kids a life that i
would want them to have like
i don't want to have kids while i'm a
drug addict like well i'm using drugs
like it's just not fair
how are you making sure that doesn't
happen
well um
i mean i do like protection of course
and you know i
i did have a steady boyfriend there for
a little bit so we you know
um it's just to be honest with you i
don't really know like i i would say
like i
i just just happened that way i was
lucky like you know i could have been
pregnant
um because i've had two abortions so i
told myself the next time i ever get
pregnant like i'm gonna have it because
i have to again
i can't have the abortions you know but
i haven't taken any precautions to that
to be honest with you and
i have gotten lucky in that sense so
it's like why
i should start i should start you know
changing my life around now because it's
like
i'm still in the place where i can like
you know have a kid without with being
clean i can get clean and still have
okay
because you're you're so like mentally
together and attractive there's going to
be so many comments saying
oh girl just get yourself together and
just just quit and yeah it's like
it's it's it's so annoying hearing that
because
if it was that easy like i would have
done it you know
long ago i would have done it a long
time ago like it's
and you know my mom and dad they always
say things like it make me feel so
terrible like
why are you doing this to our family
like why are you doing this to us like
don't you love us and like stuff like
that it's like i love them with
everything
in my heart like every inch of my heart
every
i love so hard like that's the thing
another thing about drug addicts is that
we feel so deeply we feel so like
emotionally
and deeply inside of us like that it's
like almost too much
you know and we're trying and so when
things happen to us you know we
like especially me like i just lose it
like i'm like i mean it's
so hard for me to go through these
emotions because i feel
so hard and that's something that i you
know i think a lot of people don't
realize is that we're just trying to
numb that
you know we're i'm such an empathetic
person like when someone else is going
through something like i feel that
like i feel their pain and i'm always
like i'm like it's too much to bear i'm
just you know i need to like numb that
feeling
it sounds like you still have friends
though yeah i do yeah i still have
friends uh
you know i still i like i have my
girlfriends back home they could not be
any different than me though like
they're all
super successful you know one works for
twitter
one is you know a nurse one's a doctor
one's a model one you know
and then it's like oh here i am like the
drug addict the homeless drug addict and
it's like
that's why like i also use cause i'm
like i don't want to think about that
like i'm
i don't want to think about the fact
that like i threw away my life like
pretty much
um and they're just all like these
successful women beautiful successful
women you know that's really hard
and when i go home that's a bit and see
my parents it's another big questions
like
don't you see your friends like why you
know why don't you want to follow in
their footsteps or
what you know and it's like why i don't
even want to go home
yeah it's like i don't even want to go
home anymore i see anyone because it's
like
that's all i hear that's all i hear is
such a huge part of
what i hear in these stories shame is so
it literally eats you
up and one thing i learned that people
tell me in treatment or
was that like they're just like you know
you gotta let go of that shame and guilt
because
what is that even doing for you you're
holding on to shame and guilt but why
like why are you doing that to yourself
you know it's like it's not helping you
like
but again it's one of those things where
it's so much easier said than done
um but it's true it's like it's not
helping it's you sit in that shaving
guilt
it's just like you know it's just you
it's like a cycle it's just you sit but
think of all the things you've done
you're in guilt you use now you're in
shame
you know it's like okay it's like a
cycle and it's just like you need to
look
i need i need to find a way to break the
cycle um
so you know that's and stay there and
stay in there you know
i've gotten like the longest time i've
had cleans probably like six months
and that to me was like a miracle how
did that happen
uh i went to uh rehab and when i got out
i
went to really good sober living and as
soon as i was living in arizona at the
time
um and i stayed close to the community i
gained a fellowship
which is i think the most important
thing is like finding people that you
can trust that are clean
and live like a good like a lifestyle
that you that you envy
kind of like like i had a great sponsor
and i stayed connected i stay connected
went to meetings
um i showed up for people who needed
help
i was really into like helping other
women
i love you know i'm an open book i wear
my heart on my sleeve and i
i like to help women especially because
i like i said grew up a really lonely
life and like i didn't have like
like that woman woman to
like role model to look up to my mother
was very shut off and didn't
you tell me much about anything and so
um i i
you know i showed up for them and that's
what helped my sobriety is
showing up for others is a big reason
why like i stayed clean during that time
is six months long enough do you feel in
rehab
with a longer stay ahead well i went to
rehab for um
four months and then i went to sober
living which is like kind of like a
halfway house
um for two months so honestly like
no like i feel like rehab should be like
a year like
more it's some that are 30 days i'm like
you're not even like detoxed at that at
that 30 days you're not even like
the drugs aren't even at your system yet
so
yeah i would say like a year or plus
would be ideal for rehab i've heard that
exact comment so many times from addicts
who have gotten clean
is is without at least a year year and a
half
you're just going to relapse yeah it's
true because
you have like it's you it's more that
it's not
the drugs are just as like you know what
we use but we need to fix what's in here
and there's really no time limit to that
like you know there's
it's no guarantee that like okay like
three months you're gonna be yeah you're
you're gonna be great you're gonna be
with all the deaths all the fentanyl
deaths
happen lately how do you feel about that
you know when i first went to rehab they
told me like you're gonna you're gonna
see a lot of these people are gonna lose
their lives like you know you're not
three maybe four people out of this room
and there'd be a room full like 40
people like
are going to make it like are actually
going to get this thing
and i was like that's like such a lie
like you know so going seven times
i've lost i don't know i would want to
say like over like 40 people
um to fentanyl like so far like since
like in the last like
two years so yeah yeah
probably more and you know it's like you
go on facebook and every day is like a
new person up there like
oh another so-and-so died overdosed so
and so died overdosed you know and some
of these people are people that you
never think like
you know like we're even like you know i
have friends back home that i never even
thought would
use drugs like they use fentanyl one
time and
they're gone and then there's people
like me where i've been using it now
fentanyl like probably like the last six
months and
steadily now there's carfentanyl too
which is like an even stronger form of
fentanyl
and i think when you're using it are you
worried about that or is it just
no no
no you need your face and uh i was
telling i
like for me like it's like you wanna
it's like the closest thing to dying
without dying
is like i'm currently so depressed that
like
just wanna be in that state of
because someone's like why do you want
to do that to yourself it's like i just
want to feel nothing
and i said i want to be as close to
death as possible without actually dying
and that to me is like getting high on
fentanyl do you
did you feel loved as a child you think
with your family um
i felt loved yes but i didn't
feel like i could
i didn't feel like i felt loved but i
didn't feel
like i could be my i didn't it's like a
weird
i can't explain it but i i definitely
know i was loved but i don't think that
like i was like able to like be who i
really wanted to be i felt i had to plea
yeah exactly i felt i had to please i
was
very like always wanting i'm a very i'm
a person that likes to please everyone
and it never gets me anywhere
but i felt like i'm almost like i had to
please my parents
um but i didn't and i definitely know
there was
love but it just didn't feel like there
was any room for me to be myself or like
know who i was because i was constantly
trying to like please my mom please my
dad
like things that they wanted me to do
but i never really didn't got to do like
anything that i
i didn't get to know myself i think i
think what you just said is probably the
most
important part of your story because
after doing so many of these talks the
difference between love and
unconditional love is
is huge and yes you are loved by your
parents
but if you really break it down you were
conditionally loved by your parents and
that's a very different story
yeah and then you end up going through
life as an adult never feeling like you
were truly
seen truly loved yeah mm-hmm it's like
weird
and that's hard to deal with so drugs
are the other remedy yeah and then
addiction comes after and
now now you're in you're stuck in
quicksand and you can't get out yeah and
it's weird to me when someone tells me
that they love me or like
you guys will be like like i love you or
i'm like what the [ __ ]
and then then the other the next chapter
of that is
which i've seen many times is when
somebody truly loves you
you can't accept it yeah yeah you'll
flake you'll reject it you'll push it
away you'll do
you'll sabotage it somehow yeah and
that's why i was interested because it's
not
what you experienced as love what you
experienced with love is that
conditional
yeah screwing with from your parents
and and that's the only situation that
you're going to
be satisfied with not something better
and not something
different but that that that's a hard
thing to
break free of yeah like what i was gonna
say was that i
i find it very strange like almost when
people like love me because i'm like why
you know like what do you see me that i
don't see in me because i
was like i said i'm so hard on myself
i'm
just you know so when people like
see things in me like that like positive
that like actually like
positive uh traits and stuff i'm just
like what
i don't know it's like i just wish i
could see myself that way
but i don't like when i look in the
mirror sometimes like i've like even
like been like i've even cried i'm like
oh like you're just disgusting i tell
myself that it's like who wouldn't feel
that way after telling themselves that
all the time you know it's like
people always like say good things about
yourself in the mirror like some
positive
like you know things about yourself i'm
just like i can't it's like i don't i
can't bring myself to do it because i
don't see that
and the more you try to do it the more
you feel
bad about yourself yeah right yeah yeah
and it's like i know like doing the
drugs and
going down this road is not is not
what's going to
make my life better but it's like i just
want to feel better in that moment
that it's like it doesn't matter like
i need to feel better and i need to feel
better right now
so like like even knowing that it's like
i don't know it's just
i just need to fix feel better in that
moment and that's to me that all that
matters is like i know like
like right now like this is my only
outfit um
like this you know i haven't showered in
days and i haven't eaten and you're
still beautiful
thank you thank you so much and that's
why it's like
dude like but you can't hear that no
yeah i could tell you that a billion
times
yeah yeah exactly and i'm just like no
like
stop you know did you do you think an
environment
a situation where where you are getting
nothing but
respect and kindness and dignity and
there's
none of this abuse that you're getting
here on skid row or the streets
might actually turn your thinking around
and make you able to love yourself and
accept love from others
do i think sorry just an environment
where you are constantly treated
consistently treated with love and
respect and dignity
do i think that might change your
thinking about yourself and maybe make
you able to accept
uh on their life that's i mean
i i hope i i don't know
i don't know the answer to that because
i haven't felt i don't know what it's
going to take it's hard it's hard to
even imagine hard to imagine
yeah you're living in a tent yeah it's
definitely living on the street
yeah it's definitely hard to imagine
that um
i want to i want that so badly but i'm
not sure i'll ever you know
29 years of feeling something and then i
don't what does it take to change it i
don't know i can't just change
change direction yeah so
i would i would love to say yes but you
know i yeah you know i
i do feel the love though like down here
like some of the people that have gone
through the most horrendous lives like
like have gone through the most
craziest things i've ever heard are the
most loving people i've ever met
so it's like why am i not like you know
what what are they doing like what
what are they you know it's it's crazy
like some of the people down here are
just so
loving and they are you know had
gone through hell their whole life so
i'm like what the hell
like what are they doing what did they
have to experience that i didn't
like when is it gonna when am i gonna
learn like to at least like and i do
love other people a lot like i can love
other people
you know i love i care i'm very caring
but when it comes to myself it's like
like i don't
give that love to myself like i do to
others
like i write you know i give like my
shirt off the right i give my shirt off
back to some my back to somebody before
you know doing something that's cliche
but it's true that you need to love
yourself in order to love others and if
you loved yourself
that loved and accepted and forgave
yourself and just loved yourself
completely
you'd you'd be more able to be kind and
loving to others
and you'd still be taking care of
yourself in fact the more you give to
others the more you'd be taking care of
yourself
yeah that's that's why i you know when i
see parents and they're just worried
about their kids worried about their
kids worried about their kids
and not treating themselves so well like
no take care of yourself you take care
of yourself and you're going to
naturally take care of your kids your
kids are going to pick up on that
and it'll just be a positive cycle of
love and kindness because you're taking
care of yourself yeah
you'll naturally take care of your kids
but when you're just trying to take care
of your kids
and you don't really count your kids
pick up on that and
yeah and the cycle continues it's true i
think that's what happened with my mom
is like
she she's an alcoholic she's my god my
whole life but now it's like
she never really took care of herself
did she come from an alcoholic family
my grandparent like i guess i drink i
don't know much about my
they're very my mom's side my family is
very secretive there's a lot of things
that they don't tell but um
i guess my mom grew up with it's always
a sign yeah
exactly like so i guess there was a lot
of alcoholism when my mother was
my mother was younger growing up but
when i was when they were taking care of
me and stuff like they
they never there was no alcohol house
they never drank um
but my mom really like just didn't take
care of herself like she worried about
me constantly she still does
um she's constantly like she'll text me
and be like oh my god like
like what like what are you doing like
you know it's like way past i'm like mom
i'm 29 years old and i'm
homeless like there's really not much
you can say to me like you know like to
be like
like nicole what are you doing like how
are you supporting yourself huh how do
you support yourself
um i when
a female hesitates i kind of i know what
the answer might be yeah
men um definitely
um are a big part of that like guys
you know sleeping around with men i've
definitely done
my fair share of that um that's that's a
quick and easy way to make good money
yeah um just recently like and i've
learned it's now for men as well as
women i used to assume it was just women
yeah i know that had that option but now
i've learned that i was wrong
men are they won't admit it as easily
but but they're making money
the same way yeah i believe yeah
at all but a lot yeah i mean just
recently like i had a couple
i like i say clients but i'm like that's
such a it's too fancy of a word
but i was selling photos to them
um just uh naked whatever they kind of
wanted type thing
um videos uh whatever they wanted like
like i
they'd give me money to go to the sex
store and i would you know
get you know things that they wanted me
to do and i would film it and i would
send it over and they would
then get you know just give me the money
venmo me like
i think the most like recently i made
was like 300 for a video
like a six second video of doing like
who likes like
why wouldn't i do that you know like
through only fans or just
no it's just like i met a couple people
and on instagram a few guys messaged me
and we're just like
like you know hey would you do this like
and i i was so like down now at the time
that i
i was like well what if they don't send
me the money and so i just did it
anyways and like
he sent the money right after and i got
lucky because like a normal you know a
lot of people would just probably be
like oh god like wouldn't send the money
over and got my video but
he sent the money and like we stayed in
touch and you know
like it was just you know it just
happened where
i could started consistently setting
this person's videos and um
yeah and he had money and he just wanted
to spend it on that i guess so
um like recently he like just kind of
uh recently he kind of cut that off and
he said he's going through family stuff
so now i'm just like okay now i gotta
like go back to like doing like the
the stuff that i don't want to do type
of stuff like more like the sleeping
with the men
and the hooking up with them for the
money that that
video stuff kind of kept at least for me
not to like have to be physical with
guys which was
like but you know starting only fans i
was like thinking about it i was like
maybe i should do that or
you know and then i'm like why wouldn't
people it's such easy money and then
it's like i forget that some people like
actually like have like they like those
morals where like they don't want to
you know show up their bodies and stuff
like that and i was i started to feel
bad about it because i'm like
oh like there was a day when i would
never
consider doing something like that you
know and now it's like
i'm in my head i'm like why wouldn't
people do that it's just so crazy how
like things have changed for me
because of like the addiction and stuff
like that so
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned from all the all
of this
um just to like
really like be like be yourself like
don't
don't be like afraid to be who you truly
are because that's that's who that's
what i feel like i
wasn't doing like i was afraid to to
show people the real side of me and i
i would say just like live life like to
just be who you want to be like that's
that's what i've always
wanted it's just like i want to find who
you are and
love that person and live that like live
to your fullest like
don't let like other people like don't
spend your whole life trying to please
others like because it's never gonna be
like
you're never gonna please it's never
gonna be enough like you think that
tendency came from the way your
parents conditionally yeah yeah
i really i truly believe that like don't
worry about other people um you know
be it just do what you love and like be
who you are and
if that's not enough to someone then
they don't need to be a part of your
life like
don't sit there trying to please someone
it's like to loving you or
so um yeah i would say that would be
like the most important thing is just
like be who you are and
rock it like if someone doesn't like you
then that that's them like
that's a big thing for me is like i'm
constantly concerned if someone likes me
or not
you know did i bother do i piss them off
like who [ __ ] cares like if they're
your friend at the end of the day
they're gonna be there for you so you
know
that's what that's what i would say
would be mine that's a good one
thanks nicole thank you so much for
talking to me
thank you so much for this amazing
opportunity it was very interesting
thank you
i wish you the best thank you so so much
yeah i
you know it's so much more like with
that i'd love to share with you
like if you'd like like want me to yeah
down the line
you can do this again really fun yeah i
do that sometimes yeah i would love that
okay oh thank you thank you yeah you're
so interesting thank you